[Music]
foreign
happy Fourth of July we didn't get to
see each other on Friday or talk but I
hope you all you [__] had a
happy fourth hopefully you got all your
fingers
I know a lot of [__] are
walking around with eight fingers today
in the story you know what I'm saying a
lot of [__] walking around with
eight fingers a couple guys are just
elbowing it to death right now today the
fuse went too fast you know what I'm
saying I've been there I've seen fingers
flying no biggie no biggie you'll be all
right in about a year by next Fourth of
July you'll learn a new [__] drill
you'll learn how to learn how to throw
it with the hook you know what I'm
saying and you'll be fine
the hook always works the firecracker
goes farther when you use a hook
laughs
Josh Wolf what did you say that the
other night did you see the aerial
footage of La did like next time just
[__] tell people yeah you can't make
dick illegal now not right now now
people are gonna blow up there were
bombs going off by my house I woke up
this morning with a leg in front of the
little Iraqi leg in front of my house
like that I just threw it in a [__]
garbage there was there were more
fireworks in my neighborhood but like
not like like pop pop like
legitimate I was in my office I thought
a bomb went off I would have checked on
my family I'm like you guys all right I
will tell you though July 5th is the
best day today was the best [__] day
to go on YouTube because all you see is
drunk people fighting at barbecues
people holding on to firecracker for too
long and white dudes firing firecrackers
out of their [__] it's the [__]
best day to be on YouTube you see more
dudes with bottle rockets propped up on
a [__]
chair yeah today was the day to be on
YouTube you know what else today last
week I did a podcast ready for this one
about how it was my wife's and I 20th
anniversary last Wednesday
but you know it's also what this week is
it's our 25th anniversary we met July oh
my second
1995 this weekend in Seattle in fact it
was the same setup because we did have
an open mic Monday
the 4th of July was Saturday and I went
down to the underground I looked in the
window I'm like oh my God I rubbed The
Brick
I'm like I'm finally here yeah at the
underground [__] and then we had an open
mic Monday you came in with your hat and
I jumped right on your dog what's up
with the Boston Network yeah yeah yeah
I'm surrounded with all these people
Yama because uh whatever the [__] but
it's 25 [__] years I know you know
holy [__]
I didn't want you to feel old but
[__] get my [__] god for 25 years
you came in on a Monday
you got to go back to Lobo Loco yeah and
then I think we finally Tuesday you hung
out it's Tuesday you can hang on that is
crazy 25 years this week I had no idea
it was this week I got there like
Jilla I did the trip how soon when you
got there how soon did you make it down
to the underground like how long had you
been in Seattle you got there and did a
trip you got the truth yeah I did the
triple run
on a Saturday night
it had to be I was in LaGrange Oregon
with Carol no I was alone see how far it
is from Lagrange Oregon to Seattle
Washington
so you were you were by yourself I was
by myself my deal was to do a triple run
to Lead Me
to Seattle to drop me off
a few hours from Seattle who do you have
any do you remember at all who you were
doing that run with
some shitty [__] oh no no I don't
remember his name but he was a really
really good guy as a matter of fact he
lived in like Laguna Beach it's about
325 miles so 325 miles divided by 70
miles an hour is what five hours five
hours I think I did it like three hours
because she was getting out of work at
the strip club at two
and I beat her to her apartment she left
me a key under the mat yeah and I went
in and she came home from the strip club
so that was a Saturday night at Two yep
I was at the underground the next day by
lunchtime I had attention
yeah man you understand me like I don't
know I don't know what you're talking
about she's talking about going to pick
Pike's Market yeah and I'm like go [__]
your mother in the ass let's go see the
underground yes
so we took like a [__] cab down to
the underground it was closed it was
lunch time I was like [__] and I rubbed
The Brick
I could tell that there was a bar like I
was like
the bar upstairs yeah yeah the [__] is
this this is not what was told and how
how had you heard about the open mic on
Monday did you ask somebody at spawny's
because there wasn't like an internet
you were looking at it was closed that
Saturday yeah and it was closed that
Sunday for the Fourth of July weekend
God so I called like Monday
and Ron Reed called back and he's like
oh tonight's the open mic
because I'd like oh Rick Kearns gave me
the the the do you remember Rick Kearns
gave me the
he goes when you go up there tell Ron
Reed you're a friend of mine tell Fox
you're a friend of mine so I took all
the Ron Reed Ron Reed just said go down
to the thing and sign up Carl was there
the best he put me up like number one
because they always put you up first the
first night yeah you went up first the
host that got 50 bucks yep 50 bucks how
much is 50 bucks back then a lot when
you host on a Monday and you got 50
bucks come on man and then my girl had
the contest in Tacoma
oh yeah
yeah [__] thing in Tacoma yeah that's
how we made a living Mondays Mondays was
our biggest living yeah if you won the
contest you won a yardstick and you'd
come back to follow Monday and host but
also you know what else you uh we did a
bunch up there was we would find we
would find one-nighters that we knew
weren't gonna last but for like two or
three months you got a paycheck to host
or whatever you know what I mean like we
we must I personally must have started
and failed 15 rooms at least I mean so
[__] money so they lose
but
like I still remember you taking me to
an under
we used to do it was pretty much the
same [__] Monday Tuesday was the
underground Wednesday was a Laura
Crockett gig one of those gig Thursday
we crashed somebody's well no Wednesday
we start the underground because
Wednesdays it was still somebody's night
yep so at least I had a night sorry Lee
we're coming down yeah we're coming we
did a lot of people's yeah we're coming
down on Wednesday night did you worry
about nothing did any of those guys let
you tour with them up there who who took
you out on the road Vince Valenzuela so
I got there on a Monday all right yeah I
got down a Saturday
this is how I tell people like I tell
people like listen
when you're dealing with me you're
dealing with the wrong guy like when you
if you come to me and tell me your story
you're dealing with the wrong guy
because you're not gonna stop me yeah so
I got there on a Saturday at two in the
morning I was at the underground at 12
the next day which is the Lord's day and
it was closed okay yeah you want to talk
about love for comedy and then I was
back there
Monday up might start at eight I was
there at seven at attention like my
[__] like I was about to go on in
Madison Square Garden
I went up there and he told me come back
tomorrow night then I came back the next
night
and then Wednesday somebody turned me on
to something somewhere in Ballard yeah
Wednesdays
those were the nights that we would find
a place just to [__] if you give us
150 bucks we'll put up 15 Comics or
we'll put up four Comics whatever we can
put together again you ready for this
that Thursday I already got a call
I'm going to remind you of another story
that you're gonna so all these people at
home could remember
that Thursday I already had a call from
John Fox you're working Friday and
Saturday in in Idaho at that time Moscow
Moscow Idaho and you know who the
headliner was wait Vince Valenzuela get
out and he treated me like a gentleman
he was a good dude he's a good good dude
he's on Facebook yeah I sent him a
message a while ago he didn't hit me
back so I don't know if he does comedy
anymore he does he does he's a great
brother to me super nice guy you did
that for you did that gig for 50 bucks
well 75 bucks and he mailed you a check
yeah
yeah you had to drive back from there
[__]
Prairie farts yeah which is tequila with
Tabasco sauce in them yeah I remember
still seeing the New England Patriot
quarterback at the airport Drew Bledsoe
Drew Bledsoe went to that school
Washington state Washington Washington
State so it was [__] crazy because
because Moscow is right across the line
from Washington so Washington State and
and what's in Moscow is what University
Ave
Idaho maybe something like that but so
they're right next to each other so yeah
those Washington States I got work
before the first week I already featured
for Vince Vale as well
how much I drove home on [__]
Saturday going like wow now it's that
easy like I just came up here yeah and
[__] slapped [__] into a first
week of work that's [__] crazy okay
then me and him were eating lunch I was
eating free lunch at his bar one day
about three or four weeks laying on my
I'm eating [__] the chicken mole that
was tremendous oh that dude made the
best
[__] and I would just leave him a sip
and his and he would give me like a
check and I was just push it away and
his brother with the fake eye because he
got stabbed in it yeah
do you still remember when homeboy
walked in and started a fight with me
we don't remember that fight that that
day because I went up there with [__]
roller skates on like I was in no mood I
just came from Denver
oh no no no no no no no no you still
remember what yeah yeah I just came from
[__] Denzel where there's no action
where I would drive to [__] Wyoming
to do an open mic you got the wrong
[__] you got the wrong guy I
would drive to Wyoming on Thursday
nights to do an open mic so stop with
your [__] so right after that I
[__] wanted to tell because then
Alberto gave me work the following week
at the old Improv the improfit closed in
Seattle that was right across right
across from Pike's Market yeah and then
we were going to Bart downstairs across
the street oh [__] come on who the [__]
you thinking that was the old improv
theater I think the club was the
impromptu out there that's what Steve
McGrew got yeah yeah yeah so it was a
theater that was The Improv the cross
the street from Pikes Peak is deja vu oh
yeah 50 ugly girls and one fat one
whatever and then across the street from
that is Pike's Market in those days yeah
and across the street from Pike's Market
on the side was a little bar we used to
go to on the side you could sneak in it
was a white people bar but Rob Lowe yeah
right long used to take us uh
light-skinned brother married to a white
chick good dude I just talked to him a
couple weeks ago every time I see him I
showed I called my wife my I call him
zombo but I call my daughter zombo but
he was he was good to you up there too
right along with me
yeah man he was like Rogan yeah he was
like bring it [__] yeah he was good to
you he was like bring it you're gonna go
up there and throw heat bring it because
I want to follow him he was a really
solid guy I still leaving messages hey
dude what do you think of him and he'll
call me back Joe Dion what the [__] is
wrong with you Josie
yeah man he was a good guy who who was
so the first person who used to have an
Altoid cam yeah filled with the best
weed yeah that was grown and he had good
weed every time he'd show up and he
treated him like a [__] like a pot of
gold it was an Altoid can that he'd fill
up with weed that was just I remember
trying to steal a butt from him one time
he's like yo Diaz don't think about it
the most important thing is I know
you're 20 years you know and uh
you've had a lot of success in LA but
now you got the thing you came here for
yeah my own talk show you got yourself a
little talk show just run me through him
and get you out of here well
uh you know it's something I've always
wanted to have my own talk show right
and this is going to be it's gonna be on
CMT which is perfect for me
um because they're trying to Branch out
and make it more of a middle of America
programming and it's kind of the
structure I guess is kind of like
Chelsea was where there's going to be
two panels we're not going to do a lot
of I'm never going to mention the
Kardashians or Bieber or the housewives
because I don't give a [__] but I will
talk about things like
um okay you know we I just saw an
article where uh the the Boy Scouts have
outlawed water guns they don't have Boy
Scouts so my thing is like when when did
we get so [__] soft right so it'll be
more like social issues but with funny
people so if you made more a little
dumbed down a little bit
all the things that we wanted to look
look you know my buddy admitted to his
wife of 10 years that's six years in he
got a hand job from a masseuse a week
later she's divorcing him three kids ten
years in
I just want to talk about [__] that I
have an opinion about you know these
Instagram models who [__] James Harden
and then tweeted out a picture of him
sleeping next to her what the [__]
things that I want to talk about right
so that'll be and then the the third act
I won't do any interviews because I
don't I don't really care that much
about that I'm a really curious dude so
it's gonna be like a grown-up Show and
Tell man I'm gonna have people come on
the show and teach me how to do [__]
that I've I don't know how to do that's
what it'll be and I'll have some of you
guys join me you guys will be up in the
panel and stuff but I hope you guys join
me too I'm just gonna for me I'm gonna
do what I think is funny period and you
know you know my sense of humor it's a
little goofy sometimes it's I would call
it intelligently stupid no sketches I
will do some field pieces I love to do a
sketch I'll be going to your house and
you're looking at your phone bill just
shaking your head you remember that and
all of a sudden your brother comes out
of the room with a bucket of Kentucky
Fried Chicken
great Kool-Aid
you know everything black and also he
puts it on the table and you go dog
who's been calling Compton Crenshaw you
remember that I don't know nobody
I go what he goes I don't know anybody
in Crenshaw I was like you teaching
crunchy you that's where you teach
remember he was adamant dude I did not
make those phone calls who the [__]
nobody else knows
black people at the comedy store that's
all I know dude you're coming on the
show yeah the 13th right no no the
Sunday yeah Sunday the
the who the [__] yeah 11 12 13 14 Sunday
the 14th at what time uh 11 o'clock 11
o'clock we'll do a bunch of you guys
that like triple is going to come on
love Tripoli Ryan sickler I like you
know all guys that I think are [__]
funny
because why not it's like you said
I got however long I have to prove
myself might as well do what makes what
I think yeah that's it yeah go from
there
are you doing Lisa all right buddy I'm
good you're looking good feeling good
Billy when you got your little whose
shirt is that tell Joshua is this the
that's the Suge Knight sure it was like
shooting night that's what you might
wear when Tupac got shot
I mean he's he's withering away he's
like he's a bad [__] he went to
Jujitsu Tuesday night to the beginning
of class for the first time
huh what did they teach you
um what a single and running the pipe I
don't know what and you knew how to do
this angle already there's this is a
little different wrestling you have to
like kind of like drop an e and go and
were you a wrestler
that's a very loose term I was I was on
the team what were you wrestling at oh
wait
I think I started High School like 160
and by the end I was like 189.
those little singlets I [__] uh
was your senior picture in the singlet
no God
oh God do you have any pictures of you
in that singlet I hope not I think you
should bring one in I would [__] love
to see that I'll have to go check
I think you should change it make it
your your Facebook profile pic oh no
it's terrible but yeah [__] Savage
this guy I went down with Zach last
night and it was awesome was it good how
long was the class an hour uh hour and a
half
that's where I started vmac it's a good
little school right right around the
corner here good guys you're taking Jiu
Jitsu for a while though two [__]
years now yeah Zach said you're like the
highest striped white belt like yeah
Stripes oh please I got like three
Sprite white belts I don't want to get I
don't want to be a blue
Buffs and [__] yeah I'm touching my feet
I got that fungi pillow do you when you
get a massage you don't rub your feet
what's that when you get a massage you
don't let them rub your feet
well who gets a massage you don't get a
massage no after you work out you don't
let some little Thai woman walk on your
back I go over here there's a little
[__] place on Lankershim they do a 20
happy hour at lunchtime yeah no hand job
on them they got the chance to go in
there they soak you're going nearly they
soak your feet and then they rub your
body and they you have your pants on
your clothes on she rubs it's one of
those people on your legs yes they put
cream they rub your hands they rub your
shoulders so you don't let them rub your
feet ah
if they're ugly
right there by the little store the
General Store yeah in there by the pizza
place they got a little massage in their
[__] little [__] Tuesday and
Thursday this chick is really like a
muscular Chinese woman really so when
she [__] digs into you and gets in
she digs in there I should have gone
today I've never gotten a massage never
no you should go over there let it be
well I promise I don't know how to go I
don't like people touching me I don't
like people behind me that's your
[__] that's your [__] exposed they
always got the drop on you you know what
I'm saying no matter how much martial
arts you know if you got your face
looking down and you're thinking about
something else your fingers are gonna
get in your ass then you're going to be
caught and they're going to hold you
down and then a bunch of those Chinese
people that come with a finger banging
and you're sitting there going no no oh
my God and You're Gonna Go why'd this
happen because I gave up my God you
never give up your [__] back you
don't switch governments I don't [__]
switch governments I don't give up my
God let me get some responses yeah got
it can't [__] do it so the show
premieres June 11th Tuesday Friday
Saturday Sunday Thursday night at 11
o'clock please set your [__] vhrs do
me the solid let's get this [__]
you you you you're laughing at that
aren't you he got close
he was laughing he makes me a distance
Hey listen if you got a VHS unset that
[__] hey it works
it all goes through the same [__]
place [__] make sure the videos
on channel three I mean he loves the VCR
bit oh he loves y'all
listen I ain't [__] around with you
people all right you said three times
and there would not be any like any
Edibles and then we had like one
175 do you mind if I do this
visibly something has happened to him in
the last five minutes yeah whatever that
Taffy is is pretty strong
nothing that's it living living who
gives a [__] about living it's overrated
my mama coming over tomorrow yeah
afterward all right then nobody okay you
can sleep all day and clean up your
little Jew helmet you'll be ready for it
when she gets home what's the matter
[Laughter]
because I want to say to you
[__]
forget right now those stars are coming
on strong are they coming out strong
they're coming on strong but I I just
like I I didn't get my I had no game at
all in high school like I didn't I
remember I got blue balls for the first
time
after my senior prom and everyone took a
bus like they we've taken limos in
junior year but senior year the school
just had a bus for everybody yeah and I
was sitting next to my friend and I was
like what is happening to me like I was
like doubled over in pain
he's like oh yeah that's blue balls like
that that was like
I was in I was a senior in high school I
didn't lose my virginity until uh I
think I was like 20 or 21. let me ask
you a question
how much can you see right now with your
eyes partially open I I'm like do you
like George Costanza who yeah I can see
everything can you still see everything
oh yeah because they're I mean your eyes
are like kind they're like in that
picture right there oh yeah that's a
perfect picture that's a perfect
I don't even notice that my eyes look
like that hey you said something to me
earlier this week that you have never
said to me that you and I have never
talked about
and I could I it was
I couldn't believe it's way you waited
this long to say it we were on the phone
and you said something to me you said
you remember you said something about
you said something to me eight years ago
and it was kind of harsh
and I was like and I was like you were
like because you were talking about
we're talking about Gavin and you said
but you said we talked on the phone
about eight years ago and you said some
[__] to me that was pretty harsh but I
went back and thought about it
and didn't take it personally
but you and I had never talked about
that before like it it's been it has
been like eight years no it was longer
than it ten years yeah yeah you were mad
for a while everybody gets mad
but the drug thing kind of wore my
welcome it's a few people yeah you were
one of them you know there was just a
few people Rogan was real close to
saying it
uh
uh there's just a few people that were
real close to say that but hold on
before you go there I gotta say
something to you because
I had no sexual experience and I always
mix up the dates
and then I went on a tear how I I had to
be 15 and I finally diversionized this
one girl
and then I dated two more girls back to
back that wanted no part of nothing not
even dry humping on the bathroom floor I
had one at a birthday party on my kid on
the floor let me try humping and she's
like I'm not getting on the floor I'll
never forget that
then
I gotta call mine balzano got me this
job going into my sophomore year before
I had to go to the hospital for my lung
infection yeah they got me this gig on
the bus as a monitor
some people went on trips you had to
give out 20 salami sandwiches and [__]
they're paying me like 800 a week one of
those jobs
and there was this girl and her name was
Lydia
and you know when uh
and we've all had this experience that
we've grown up with a girl and also we
we see her when she's 15 or 16 well this
girl isn't just a [__] girl it's 16.
she's a [__] woman curves you get the
whole thing like she's got the whole
thing and you just look at her and go oh
my God this girl is banging but it'll
never work out for me
so I had to spend the week up in this
District which was Uptown with this
Lydia girl and every day we went to
Jones Beach we went to a museum and I
gave out the sandwiches
and you know what by Thursday
I'm flirting with that and I got a
chance I never had a chance with a girl
like this but I don't just have a chance
to make out with she's talking about sex
and I'm like at this time you're using
using rubbers at all
and that's exactly how it went down
for for years you struggle to have sex
with people you struggle to find the
words and one day it's real mistake I
said something like that bikini looks
good on you or something she played me
back she goes you got to see what's
under it and all I'm saying will show it
to me and we went behind a bus and she
pulled it was a bush of hair and I was
like
and I didn't know and then the next day
I saw it I'm like were you gonna let me
touch that thing and she's like come on
and we went around I touched it until
like the next day I went back and we
swapped spit and I sucked the titties
and I'm like so when are we gonna do
this and she's like wait till we get
back my my brother has a basement
with Josh it was like the weirdest
[__] thing and sure enough you know
somebody lies to you yeah and you call
them Friday I can't meet you I'm done no
here's the address went over there her
brother left us we went downstairs the
brother left yeah we got like the
brother was 22 and she was like maybe
15. you know if I was 50 yeah I was like
15 16. yeah but she was in the North
Bergen School System I had never met her
before and I had never heard of this a
Savage before like she lived near you
she went to your school I lived on my
mom was still alive
and she lived on 86th Street or
something
and it was [__] crazy I took a bus up
there and met her went downstairs took a
panties off tons of hair you know we
never you missed that bush a little bit
we never went down on each other no like
at that age no we just got together no
condom boom and then
by the time I got to high school she was
gone
like she was that much older than me and
she was gone never a leather
it was the weirdest thing and to this
day it's everyone tonight are you sure
she even existed yeah yeah yeah she was
like a pixie it was like a month
relationship that was all
dirty like that we went to the movie one
time like I tried to turn it into a if
anything about me yeah I took it to a
movie or something you ever date
somebody or hook up with somebody and
after you hook up with them they had
something about them that they probably
shouldn't let you know ahead of time
the one and only time I've ever been
with a girl who squirted right and I
went down on her and I didn't I had
heard of a squirter before but I'd never
like do you know what I mean and when
that [__] came out it's tremendous no
but it [__] if my mouth was open I
and I didn't know exactly I wasn't
expecting it do you know what I mean but
it's if you're a squirter you that's
something you kind of gotta let somebody
know going into the game like [__] no
that's a surprise
I'm not telling you nothing you are a
squirter yeah I'm not gonna say nothing
I'm gonna squirt and then go oops no
oops I was like you just gotta let
somebody know because I was not
expecting that at that have you ever
been with a squirrel no I've never been
on the one I I would I I think I would
prefer the the way Joey scored her like
if I was gonna be with a squirter I'd
prefer to be with someone like Joey who
would just like surprise me yeah you
want to be surprised no you don't want
to be yes you do you don't ever want
nobody to tell you nothing well I guess
it kind of depends on the girl like was
it like a girl you didn't want to have
sex with no let me ask you something if
you're going down on a girl and you're a
young man right right and squirting
isn't in your brain and all of a sudden
a wave of stinky bath water hits you in
the face you're not going to be
surprised like no you don't want to know
well because here's the thing I grew up
with with pornography essentially so
like it's almost like it would be like a
hidden surprise it'd be like an Easter
egg that'd be like yeah I found one
really yeah
you got a prize League oh you're the
star for that for that comment are you
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
how are those going he's a tremendous
there you go but do you remember when he
first started
when he first started what was happening
he was a nice little boy yeah he didn't
ball nobody no he still don't bother
nobody oh these are
smell them just smell those [__]
things
smell Busters
oh my God sure eat one God try it one
you'll like it try one you like it yeah
it's probably not a great idea you half
of it yeah yeah he's two tentacles
that's it
um that's it yeah we'll see what happens
later in the day so Josh this is my
second one today it is yeah yeah give me
the other hand smoke so I'm gonna hang
out with the kid
you go like this
that's your sixth one today yeah and
that's my five and a half one
I mean and you guys just sit here like
nothing
we're in training yeah yeah you're
training hard Isis kicks in the door the
Russians wearing trick they can't do
nothing no they're not getting in here
we're gonna average in a thousand 1100
milligrams a day now for a week stop it
oh yeah no wonder my kidneys are [__]
them 1100 a day
is that what you're at too 1100 a day
I'm at 1200 right now on the weekends he
eats 850 just to keep him in line you
know what I'm saying does it keep you in
shape yeah what's your what's your
girlfriend is she on board yeah well she
is a little bit but she she is looking
for lawyer jobs right now so she can't
really do it
but it stinks because when I go get it
like I get it for like her and me and
she needs like one red star Maybe
and I need about six six purple ones two
red ones
some acid little mushrooms there's only
two things we're eating now these and
those cushy things yeah [__] I don't
even know what those are oh what are
those
it's a gummy bear
it basically if it's 100 milligrams or
200 milligrams it's forced cubes
so if it's 100 it's 25 it's 200 it's 50.
do you remember the weed you used to
smoke yeah do you remember like you
could
smoke two three joints and just be like
maybe you get a headache and he still
doesn't look too good but without
getting high you could smoke two or
three joints without getting high you
don't know what we did before you got
Anthony smell this that's what
oh my God yeah this is this is this is
we got is this the is this where Owen
Benjamin walked around the neighborhood
this is it is this where is this the
neighborhood you walked around in yeah
he told me he was like I walked out and
never [__] came back no he never came
back no no he was Bruce Springsteen
bye
we could did you know he was in trouble
could you tell by looking at us there
was a couple of points there's two or
three people I've looked at so I could
tell that they're gone Ada yeah either
we were having a great time and she just
took one and eight one without even like
she just took one right and I'm like
okay she's a tall cup of coffee yeah and
about 30 minutes late I saw her eyes
going
like it was real like you when you see
it yeah oh
[__] like I I've seen remember that
remember when uh what was the movie when
they took a shopping The Devil's
Advocate when they took uh Clarice Geron
shopping and they would put the dresses
over their head and often they go ah and
she would go oh that's what happens with
this [__] like it just comes to you
little by little at first but you love
that [__] oh yeah I love to be in fear
yeah you're in my life you [__] love
you know I think about it like a uh I
think Rogan and Segura broke it down
once and like it's a great way for a
comic to live and I thought about it
that was
from 80 to 95 that's how I lived yeah I
loved living that at any time somebody
could knock on that door and say dog
what happened to the two thousand
dollars I'm not gambling that yeah you
saw it Oh you saw it you lived I lived
it you lived it yeah you know at that
timely anything
could yeah
I remember I remember Lee it being
it's this the the
the [__] I get separated October of 91
and I go on a tear for 18 months credit
cards Bongos I finally have to start
selling everything I could like neon
membership to a mob yeah but there was a
kid I was working that was a nice kid
that kept coming to me going dog if you
ever had any good Investments
no yes and I was nurturing him yeah like
that but by the way you're really good
at that oh we were talking about that
you're really good before we get to that
there's something I do got to tell you
Lee by the way were you at the comp no
you wanted the conversation kept me up
all night last week by the way happy
Rosh Hashanah thank you last week I took
a long distance flight I'm sitting in
first class I get upgraded I don't
bother you know when you get upgraded on
a New York flight you don't say nothing
no nobody no I'm sitting there I see
three empty seats the one next to me and
two over there guess who sits next to me
50 cents sits in the window while goes
to sleep I don't say two words it don't
got nothing to do with me so now I can't
go to sleep I got a few stars in me I
got the iPod in I'm excited I want to
see who's gonna win those last two seats
and all of a sudden I get caught up my
wife calls me whatever the flight to 6
a.m playing out of LAX to to Kennedy my
favorite because you're going to Delta
one and [__] what yeah what what yeah
what yeah so all of a sudden I'm sitting
there and who is it what two and Lee I
[__] up I've been slipping my right my
racially
whatever skills are low especially when
it comes to the Sea juice so
there was one 400 pound has said you
with the whole thing and his son stinky
with a [__] broken foot comes on toes
exposed the whole thing just two stink
bombs complaining from the time they get
just
complaining from the time the guy is
round he tucks his shirt in yeah before
the plane takes off he puts the vest on
he ties the ropes around his arm with
the flashlight yeah him and his son
before the plane tickets not a
flashlight okay whatever on his head
yeah okay whatever
okay so him and his son is drinking
coffee they're going the planes going
okay well everybody shut down boom okay
everybody we're headed to the thing the
plane doesn't even get to the runway I
think something cut it off the plane
goes He spills the coffee excuse me
excuse me
he's like I spilled my coffee on my new
dry cleaning uh somebody has to take
care of the dry cleaners they're an
upgrade available
you know the plane hasn't even gone into
the air and he's already talking
upgrades upgrade already me I'm a
professional I already know that if I
would own Delta I would have checked to
see who this guy was because for every
dollar you take from this he's gonna
charge you double in time and
aggravation plus he's gonna take
everything he's got but they did two
genius moves but I didn't figure out the
other night about three in the morning I
got high
and I [__] figured out with these two
Aesthetics do they're [__] beautiful
people talk about those people what's
that movie with Brad Pitt that they're
hustling oh she's 11. no
[__] woman that boxes and they lived
those people that he represents there
[__] some type of Irish people that I
even oh Gypsy snitch Gypsy they're Gypsy
snitched this Stitch whatever the [__]
snatch snatch the Gypsies and they said
don't don't double cross you listen I
didn't catch the double cross
until two weeks later with the Hasidic
Jews did though I'm surprised okay
what's the first call you got listen
before the plane took off they already
asked for a [__] upgrade the plane
took off
okay the plane's up in the air the black
guy gets a pad with your name on it he
walks right up to him and he goes is
this
and he goes yes what do you think the
first thing out of this guy's mouth was
he said
do you have my kosher mail and also the
black guy goes into a frenzy culture
right I mean he whacks them first thing
out of the gate yeah he cracks him with
the kosher meal cracks me through I'm
like I was not expecting that yeah and
also the guy's like no we're like okay I
guess I'm gonna have to talk to
management upgrades for me and my son
and he's already working it dog wow
whipping him let me get two blankets I
want a hat you know
I want the he's working them he's
working them just working them with
whips and chains well guess what at six
in the morning well guess what Lisa yeah
did he get everything he wanted no no he
tormented them he got everything he got
then the food came and he goes and said
no Kosher menus he had to pick and
choose from two other menus and they and
everything but here's the most
disgusting thing they had a bag of food
not a bag a black bag yeah they had a
bag of just Ugg salads and everything
but then like they didn't need the food
they were complaining about right now at
the end of this 40 minute later time the
guy gets up after being up and down
praying wrapping stuff around his arm
talking to his son in Hebrew he goes to
the bathroom he stays in there it takes
a 40 minute [__] no that the whole first
class and the people in the first time
Rose are in Jeopardy they're like when
is this guy gonna come out and what's
that ass gonna smell like now the guy
couldn't fit into the bathroom like
front ways he had to turn around and go
backwards you have no idea the thing
opens he comes out he walks out like hi
and all of a sudden the [__] one
black student just slams that door and
they come out in their spring
oh my God I felt so bad for them Joshua
but I figured out the whole scam
they never ordered kosher food no that
was just to get the [__] guy ruffled
up and [__] yeah and the son's foot
wasn't broken they just put a cast on
his foot just to [__] let him know we
used to do that at Disneyland yeah what
put a cast on the kitchen oh yeah the
kids get to they used to get to pick
which one of them wanted to be
handicapped there you go we used to do
that all the time there you go we used
to pick who the [__] you think you're
dealing with something happened there
because he's chubby he didn't want to be
embarrassed so he made the son put on a
fake [__] Castro wasn't a cast it
wasn't a real white cast it was a blue
one that you put together at home like
luggage who the [__] you think you're
dealing with I and I told Matt lotman
it's like oh Matt lopman they never even
ordered the kosher meal they said that
to get the guy ruffled up from the jump
that's how you do it ladies and
gentlemen you see when you do blow for
three days Lee right and then you sleep
for a day what do you think when you
wake up happens the first thing you wake
up that time I don't know Josh well
don't you have a bunch of Boogie snots
it's horrible yeah and the first thing
you do as you're pissing and looking at
yourself in the mirror and looking at
whoever fell asleep in your house we're
doing blowers as you're pissing you're
already taking the toilet paper out and
you snap it and you blow your nose and
anybody who's done cocaine has looked at
that first blow in the morning
I would take that [__] snot I
wouldn't even blow it I'd blow it into
my hand
like a Savage
and it would come out and I'd peel those
last Roots out like you gotta peel those
last pieces I do like when there's Roots
I'll be honest about that it does feel
good and there was chunkers of coke I
mean you won't be the lighting I can't
you know I did it and I did it mostly
when I saw it below but anyway I don't
want to talk about this [__] well just
after the conversation we had I thought
for an hour like
the Rises of us that we had the falls
the
the shows to what could have
we're still here 23 years later and
Brody's been hit 20 of those years with
us I mean this is pretty [__] cool
that we're still here you sent me that
picture of our first lineup together
yeah we're still at the store last night
you had a ten to nine I had an attend
tonight just to think that this started
23 years ago and nobody knew what the
[__] we're doing nobody really know but
you know here's what happened is like
the quitters lose that's basically what
happened when we first started
everybody's about as funny do you know
what I mean everybody's the same I
always say that all right listen there's
no the funniest person on the planet his
name is Ace Frehley that's the funniest
human being on the planet today he's a
top top up there with Dave Chappelle but
it's then it's hard work and then it's
who's gonna keep going that's what it is
and when you sent me that picture of
that first lineup we were on there was
only three names that are still doing
comedy me you and Chappelle that was the
other name on the list of people still
doing comedy that was it but here's what
happens
people come out here they come out with
a dream and they get a time set
and they give themselves a time set of
something and they stick out The Comedy
Store for 10 years and things don't
happen you know what Josh will
they go back to St Louis
they uh hook up with family again
and if they're real comics
they find a way to make a living they
came they saw they conquered as long as
they could Steve Cooper wrote a
beautiful
Steve Cooper said after 20 something
years
my dream didn't come true I didn't make
a lot of money yeah but I got to meet a
nice people I'm going back to
Philadelphia and live like a normal
human being you know he gave it a try he
had a podcast that was successful you
know I see is he still alive on on
Facebook he's still uh but here's that's
the thing is we kept what's that word we
kept persevering we kept going dude
we know what we kept doing is we kept
evolving see we a lot of people come and
they say this is what we do and this is
what I do and they don't evolve
as artists you're so much different dude
as as a comic and just like as an artist
and as a creative thinker then you can
sit down and write now yeah I love it
but you never could come you could never
ever ever do that sit down and write
[__] no I'm reading this book that's
making me a writing nasty so to look
today I went down there and even if it
was old jokes I wrote them out just to
see where the gaps were my timing I got
to go to work Josh well you know we want
to get to the next [__] Sentinel here
but that's the difference giving people
a good show when that half hour is not
there I feel [__] guilty if I give
you the first half hour and it's new
[__] it let's rock and roll I don't even
want you to see my full album because I
want you to [__] special anyway right
so I'm not showing up with no [__]
new hour for you because half of it's
going to be on this special let me show
up with 30 minutes of new [__] that's
gonna blow your mind
and you know 20 minutes oh [__] the
whole closed or whatever I can accept
that but that's what you were saying
earlier on the phone when you were
talking about the difference between
being able to tour with an album we
don't tour
once you put out that special you can't
do it again we cool to developed that
out yeah and then we put the tour route
we put the special out and you've
already seen three quarters of the
material right because you were there in
Buffalo the week before we [__] shot
it so that was that 2 000 people that
came to that weekend also the people
throughout the year or a year and a half
however long it took you there you've
been working that material on the road
when you put out a special they're like
oh we we [__] saw that we saw that
special whereas with musicians they tour
they put out the album first and they
Tour on their out it's completely it's
completely opposite right well I mean
don't you think I mean what I would
think it has to do with is the comedy
has to do with surprise mostly do you
think once it goes down like there are
some specials that hold up but I think
most of them the first time you watch
it's gonna be the best time but do you
think people want to come and hear jokes
from the special do you think some
people want to hear some of the jokes I
go back to music
I go back to music
and I say to myself you know what in
fact I was listening to somebody the
other day they went to see Metallica one
of those guys on Ozzie's Boneyard and he
said you know I was very disappointed
because they played all new stuff
I wanted to hear puppets or whatever and
this and destruction and you know people
go to Led Zeppelin they don't want to
hear new [__] they want to hear stay
with Heaven rock and roll Joe want to
hear we saw we saw Bob Dylan he didn't
play one hit
one [__] hit he played out at that uh
that concert out in the desert last year
with Dylan and the stones and The Who
and all those guys right so we went and
saw and I I was not too excited to see
Dylan but I I wanted as long as he's
alive let's go say and we've seen him he
didn't play one hit he didn't play one
song that anybody knew it and no he
played Tangled Up In Blue but he
rearranged it to the point and I was
like what the [__] is he doing here we
don't want to hear your new if the if
the who would come out and played a new
album we'd have been like no no who's
next who are you that's what we want
that's what we came to here though I
want you to open up with three songs
that blow my [__] heart apart and
then take a warm-up talk to us for five
minutes and say listen we're telling you
people first we're taking the who on the
road next year
this is one of the new songs of the
album that's nobody heard we love you
Indiana dun dun dun by the way that's
what the stones did that's how you sew
yeah a new a new song
you don't sell a new song like that I
used to get [__] pissed when a band
but I wanted to go see and I had a thing
in my mind what they were going to open
up with and they opened up with
something different
because I heard the night before in
Philly they opened up with this like in
those days you found out oh Philly
opened up with [__] uh
whatever how bad for whatever you're
like all right they're gonna open up and
help Ben for leather in the city and all
your buddies and you were going there
but I say no they're gonna open up a
scream with Avengers but you knew you
heard it the night before they're
opening up with hell Bethlehem you know
I'll be waiting to see what the answer
was and all sudden [__] help them for
letting your buddies go [__] you
what do you think you're dealing with a
[__] I called Philadelphia last night
the one thing I I don't I like though
with comedians I don't mind if you do
stuff from the special on the road but I
don't like if you do like one special
and then the next special has the same
jokes as the first special I've never
seen that before Oh I have who I don't
want to speak bad of them because he was
very nice to me but uh John Pinette
he had a couple specials that were just
huh very he was very nice
funny [__] guy yo he was hysterical
that and the reason why it hurt me so
much was because that was my family sat
down and watched that special I say
Nanny that was one of the funny I still
watch it now it's it's hysterical but
it's also different like because if you
go see journey and they don't play
you know Don't Stop Believing whatever
your song is you're gonna be [__] mad
but if you go see Chappelle
do you want to hear a joke you've
already heard or do you want to hear
what what he's got now okay I'm a fan of
Chappelle
since before the [__] uh show the
show okay I remember one of his albums
before that or something and that was it
I saw two of the three specials that are
on Netflix but let's pretend that was a
fan of Chappelle from the show
and
I was praying
65 70 for these tickets
I know Chappelle is brilliant enough
that he's gonna do the first 30.
is new stuff because she'll probably do
that he does everything his first dirty
is always new
you got nothing to lose no he takes you
one direction for 25 minutes an old joke
he redoes it what do you give a [__] the
audience is laughing the show's over
that's what you went to see
you know if you go on the Borgata
webpage I'm the cheapest ticket for a
comic the comic standard charts a lot of
money and I gotta tell you something I
got some badass credits and they got a
lot of money I could have raised those
tickets but I don't see it they're
talking themselves out of a market
the cable guy right so he his theory was
always his ticket was never more than
47.50 didn't matter where the seat was
didn't matter anything 47.50 was the
price of the ticket because his deal was
I would rather have more fans I don't
want to price my I don't want to give a
hundred dollar ticket I'd rather sell 10
000 tickets at the 50 than 5 000 tickets
at the 100 because one more fans but two
that's twice as many people buying merch
do you know what I mean and like you're
not pricing people out you're not making
them feel bad about buying the ticket no
that's you that's the smart thing to do
because you keep your fans your fans
never think that you're raising the
prices above them it's definitely the
way to go but dude he do I mean we sold
we he sold 53
000 tickets he sold out that Nebraska
Cornhusker Stadium because he couldn't
do the whole stadium because the stage
was was up against one of the walls he
saw 53 3 000 [__] times
Larry the Cable Guy
in that stadium and then he donated the
tickets whatever he made off the tickets
to a charity didn't keep it didn't keep
his cut he donated at all 53 000. on the
fourth of July what do you do after they
they postponed the fireworks until the
next night because he did it on the four
and everybody at the in the town was in
I think I'm remembering that right
somebody might correct me but I'm pretty
sure that's what happened they moved it
one night because he wanted to do his
show on the fourth of July that's how
many [__] people were there they
moved the fireworks oh and dude somebody
somebody this old dude was parachuting
into the stadium right at pretending to
be him right and dressed like him and it
was his last jump out of a plane ever
right and this was his big retirement
jump so he jumps out of the plane he's
dressed as Larry and you hear the voice
over I'm coming down everybody you know
whatever it is and then the wind kicks
up and we're like I don't know you could
see him start to do the pulleys you know
what I mean and we're like no he's gonna
overshoot this because he's supposed to
land on the grass hit the grass running
run behind the stage and then take his
the parachute off and then Larry runs
out on stage dressed the same way so it
looks like he
well he overshot the grass by about 15
yards and landed straight into the empty
cement bleachers broke his [__] it
coccyx you know that thing that
basically I think is your pelvic bone
right the coccyx
but the show couldn't start until he got
up and ran behind the stage so we're
like we're watching the wind go
and I'm like oh he's not gonna make it
he's starting to do the pulley things do
the pulley things and he hits that
cement and we were everyone in the
stands thought it was like part of the
thing so everyone in stadium was like
and we were all like oh no and he kind
of you could see him kind of struggle to
get up and he kind of waves his hand
over because he's got a broken coccyx
but everyone on the production team's
like no you gotta come over here right
oh my God dude rolls over
the world and listen rolls over this was
his retirement jump he was like 68 years
old right this is where he was gonna
wave goodbye to everybody
crashes into the bleachers and he
finally makes it behind and collapses
and then picks up his whatever pull him
out in a [__] ambulance
but uh
that poor old fella that was his last
jump I bet there was someone in the
ambulance like I I know you heard
yourself but next time you really should
have just ran a little fast oh no you
should when the wind kicked up everybody
in production was like this is not gonna
end well for this guy this is not good
for him but doing comedy in front of
that many people was terrible
I think that the comedy's not made for
that that size crowd because the the uh
the the laughter would come and then I'd
start my joke again and then the
laughter would come for the people that
far away
I don't care how big you get that's just
a little too big for me you don't have
to control no what's your what's your
what's the size you like the most
400 seats in a small comedy club with
bricks yeah old school like the
underground you know I know there's a
lot of comics that listen to the show
that Comedy Underground was my favorite
there's a lot of young Comics that
listen to this show and I applaud you
for trying calmly and sticking with it
and you know I know where the [__] we
both know what the [__] you are
I still remember being 1996.
and the black dude who played the piano
for Stephanie thing came up to the
underground on Fridays and Saturdays
whenever Fridays and Saturdays with a
big comic game me and Josh will always
wiggle our way into that [__] uh into
that thing this is 1997. one of us had
that empty spot this was 21 years ago
people just to let you know how hard you
got to stay in this we're talking about
living in a shitty apartment we're
talking about I lived in a car you
remember Mark's dog remember Mark
Gardener I live with Mark Gartner and
his his dog used to just [__] in the
living room do you remember that
Dalmatian that [__] Dalmatian I
walked in the house it was so dirty I
ran back to camera because I loved it he
used to let his dog [__] in the living
room when we were watching TV he was
cooking that black stuff the bones with
all the grass oh my God I had no idea
and I was doing sports booking out of
there sports buddy yeah in the back room
and that's when the guys call me and
threatened me and said if you keep doing
they'll fly out there and [__] you up
you know it's just to let you people
know what the real struggle and we're
still here this is [__] real he moved
to LA maybe six or seven months before I
did and we used to go down to the
remember we used to pick up Stanhope and
we did not say improv together in the
car right I mean this is
1997. what street did Stanhope live on
Ralphie was on Schrader and Nick depaolo
and Mitch Hedberg were on where Cibo is
yeah this is this is a comedy [__]
neighborhood and when I you know I told
people we'd go down to Gorky Park when
we moved there Gokey park at Nickelback
you could buy weeds down there and uh we
could go on and play tennis
[__] yeah 20 [__] years
yeah this was a big [__] grow when
you were when you were when we were
first starting when you first got here
what was your goal for sets per week I
know you had I had no right listen when
I first got here
I was very scared but I knew I had an
out with Carol
you know I had it out I was putting away
a little money I would clip every night
for an extra 50 from the stocking when
she stripped I had a taxa
I still had a little put away you know
but wait but you didn't know but when
you first when you first started because
you kept that notebook man we all had I
kept a notebook about every set and what
I did and all that [__] and I had a for
me I wanted to do seven sets a week that
was the goal at the time I just listened
we would come from I came from Colorado
where I was doing four sets a week and I
drove eight hours to do those sets yeah
but you were doing more in four sets in
Seattle Seattle
I get one up to 30 sets a month yeah and
we were [__] working
Monday the underground then we went to
that bar
up top whether there was cages and we
used to do comedy up there yeah that was
that was Monday night was that Dave
Henderson's batting cage was that one no
no it was no batting cage there were the
cages where women go into oh
it was a very bushwah type of place on
Monday nights so we leave the
underground open mike which was
a [__]
you know when I think of the underground
if I close my eyes and I think hard
about the underground open mic on Monday
how can you describe that that was well
the first thing I think of is Carl
honestly a woman honestly the first
thing I think about is Carl and his and
his little uh was a hat called not a
fedora but uh you know the thing the
French uh
and guys he was Brave that would help
you I don't wear French hats okay we'll
help you write jokes he would comment on
your sets whether they were good or bad
sometimes he'd come in a negatively he
would buy he'd bust your balls yeah that
joke he was yeah
[Music]
foreign